brought to you by Tom Clancy's Rainbow
six siege siege the day in stores now
rated M for Mature in Rainbow six siege
you need to know how to build the right
team whether you're fixin to storm a
plane or an industrial facility or a
spacious mid-century three-bedroom
two-bath with office workshop fully
appointed kitchen an ample garage space
the combination of operators your team
chooses is a crucial component in your
strategy here's a short list of the
roles you need to fill and how they'll
help you win let's start at the tip of
the spear with the point man this is the
big guy who is the first human through
any breach door bashed point of ingress
I say human because you should really be
using that tube on wheels drone of yours
to scout the scene before any player
actually sticks their neck out it's
worth the extra effort just be sure the
drone pilot has a teammate watching his
back in case of aggressive defenders or
better yet repel up to the roof go prone
and do your droning from up there once
you've got the scene scouted you want
montane with his extra tall shield to
stride through the door like the walking
Montaigne of steel that he is tall
shield mode means he isn't firing on
anyone so stack up one or two teammates
behind him ready to lean to either side
or you could go with blitz whose shield
has a disorienting flash bulb on the
front that'll fry your foes eyeballs
like an old-timey person posing for a
photograph any shield carrier can use a
sidearm while shielding except for
montains tall shield mode just remember
not to aim down sights and totally
expose their fleshy non shielded bits
mod their pistols with laser sights for
better hip firing and be sure to precede
their arrival with some smoke grenades
for good measure the next roles on the
roster are the device denialists it's
not that they don't believe devices
exist it's just that they don't think
defenders should be able to use them
after all the defenders arsenal includes
trip wires gas bombs c4 shock batteries
a heartbeat sensor signal jammers and
you know what these all run on power if
you knock out the power you neutralize
the device and that's exactly what
Thatcher's EMP grenades are for if you
ever see the message saying you've
detected then you know some electronic
trickery is afoot
EMP just one choke point left between
you and the hostage EMP are your
teammates breaching and assaulting EMP
just wait until your team's breach
charges are triggered or you'll mess
everything all up if you want a little
more precision bring along IQ and have
her scout for electronic signals she
pairs well with Thatcher but if he's not
around she can still give you an idea of
what awaits you on the other side of the
wall just remember that knowing is only
half the battle those support roles are
key to your success somebody on the team
or somebody's preferably needs to be the
one to make a whole breachers get you
where you need to go and no one is
breach ear then sledge unless it's like
a metal wall or it's something and this
is where map knowledge really helps give
a surface a quick rifle but to test its
smash ability and remember with great
smash' tude comes great visibility when
you're about to bring the hammer down
set up a decoy breach charge first or
coordinate with a teammate to create
multiple simultaneous points of entry or
at least the illusion of them Ashe and
her breach launcher are great for this
because she can pull attention to
another area of the room or get through
a barrier without the risks of getting
up close to set a charge most operators
will be able to take a breach charge
with them but only thermite's exothermic
charge will get you through one of those
reinforced walls that looks like a
balding Hedgehog these special charges
take a few seconds to burn through a
wall and are very showy so they tend to
draw a lot of attention use the varying
capabilities of breachers to keep your
enemies guessing about where you're
coming through and you'll be more likely
to catch them off-guard when you do
finally you're gonna need some gun guys
I mean technically everyone on your team
is a gun guy and should be ready to
shoot their gun at bad gun guys at any
time especially the pesky ones who like
to rush the attackers and suicidal
attempts trait two or three for one but
some gun guys really make guns their
thing and glass is one such guy his big
ol rifle doesn't just kill enemies very
quickly
it also punches big holes in walls
opening up big firing lines for your
team to utilize or just to make your
opponents nervous
the
mental game is real in Rainbow six siege
but with a solid crew of complementary
operators you'll be equal to the task
leave some seeds worthy tips of your own
in the comments below and breach on
breachers
you